yeah guys her stuff is good she's very
entertaining and like she's got a really
good like head on her shoulders like I
really like that your stuff is like
like sometimes you watch red pill stuff
and it's very much like Doomsday you
know what I mean a little bit and you're
like very positive like you you frame
the wall in like a positive way like I
saw a piece of content
um from you the other day that was
saying like you don't have to look at
the wall as a bad thing it just means
you know it's how you structure your
life
the wall is only a problem if you're in
denial about aging as a woman yeah
that's the only the only time is an
issue or if all of your content and
character is solely invested in your
physique that's when you struggle as a
woman every well-rounded woman I know
isn't really worried about the wall
because they're setting up their lives
accordingly for when they're going to be
40 50 60. and you know for any woman
that thinks that the wall doesn't exist
do you really think that your grandma is
as hot as she was at 18 like I just want
to know
yeah and um no and I don't know why like
it's okay to have other things in life
other than looks like it's not the
end-all be-all it's just basically
saying you're getting gonna get less hot
the older you get which is like kind of
a given
yeah and I think too that I'm a little
bit lucky that I wasn't born necessarily
a solid nine or ten and every time I say
this people want to come in like oh my
God you're so pretty no I've been to
Miami okay I know what's up I know
what's up and so for me I think also I
was overweight for a long time I
actually lost 45 pounds so I think that
that helped me to keep a real level head
and not over invest in my looks but I'm
gonna say that looks are important don't
get me wrong I'm just glad that I don't
have that Everlasting genetic makeup to
where I'm going to be super hot and
attractive and maybe like a tad
delusional at 30 or 40 because I see
that happen a lot to very attractive
women I see that too it's like their
whole value is based in their looks and
they don't really work on like
developing other skills like
communication being not not always not
always but like I see it a lot in super
attractive girls
yeah and there's always that argument
not all women not all women I get it we
all know a tall Asian but what we really
talk about isn't right we mostly just
talk about men and women on average that
that's it and unfortunately on average
men find women around age 23 24 to be
the most attractive and on average women
in the west find men to be attractive
when they're
on average four years older than them so
these things they just exist we're not
making it up I wish we were making it up
but that is not the situation yeah so um
let's talk about how you kind of found
the red pill so you were married before
right yeah yeah could you tell me about
that a little bit
yes so I was married for five years but
I I got married out of scarcity I got
married for stability it I wish it was a
beta bucks situation I think you know
what it was I had gotten married off of
potential because I think deep down
inside I knew that I wanted to stay home
with my kids I wasn't sure how long I
was gonna stay home but things had
happened within that marriage once my
spouse at the time got out of the
military where he got really regular
really quick and I started getting very
concerned because it was apparent to me
that I was going to be working for the
rest of my natural born life because
when you present a man with divorce and
then he's quick with it and starting to
change
well he's only changing because of
what's on the line it would have been
nice if the things that I had said for
the past year and a half were taken
seriously then I wouldn't be in that
position uh but it was it was a real
learning experience for me and I ended
up finding out that I was attracted to
traditionally masculine men and I didn't
expect that because a lot of the women
that I was around growing up was born to
a lower socioeconomic status they just
tell you to marry a good stable guy they
don't say anything about that attraction
piece which is very important to me
yeah I don't know why we don't ever
really talk about like traditional
masculinity at all like it's almost
frowned upon it's what I found like if
you ever say I like a masculine man it's
always
like almost there's always pushback when
I talk to like girls my age about that
anyways
well there's pushback but then look at
who they're dating it's like athletes
that are six foot tall you can just
smell the testosterone seeping off of
him from across the room so like what a
woman says she's attracted to you versus
who she actually ends up dating is two
very different things but when you when
you use that same lens as women women
they don't understand so this is what I
keep hearing is that well what men are
attracted to is different from them what
they say they're attracted to but women
are not understanding that who a man
will sleep with is going to be different
than who he will marry just two
different types of chicks so as much as
I would love I would love the attention
from dressing a lot more sexier maybe
pushing up my breasts maybe wearing
smaller clothes I would like that just
because it does make you feel a little
bit good and validated I'm just going to
keep it a stack okay but the the
attention that I'm getting for men isn't
going to be the attention that I want
and I know every time that I dress kind
of skimpy I know that I have to be like
prepared for the nonsense that's going
to come my way because I'm athletic so
I'll go out in my sports bra on my
tights if I'm just on the Move On The
Move I don't have time to do the
bathroom and change to get everything I
need done in a day but I know that
that's going to put me in a position to
be cat called and I actually I actually
don't like that that much so I try not
to do that but yeah I mean even though
I'm on the the boring side of things the
housewife side of things I just have to
remember that all I need to worry about
is if my man at home is attracted to me
I don't need the world looking at me per
se although it does feel good
that's so that's very honest right what
I love about ali she's very honest
um okay so you ended up getting divorced
from the first guy and then how did you
meet your now husband
so I knew him I knew him the whole time
I was married and this is what throws
people off because it comes into like
well the beta Orbiter maybe she was
seeing somebody on the side it was
anything like that because my fiance is
very rigid if if anybody met him in real
life for five minutes they would know
just how rigid this dude is so he
outranked me and my spouse at the time
so we never socialized out of the office
which would be the military we were both
in the military he was an officer I
wasn't listening you're not supposed to
hang out and also in the military too
it's like perception is reality so if
you're hanging out with a hot little
young honey people are gonna think
things about you people are gonna assume
things and you're gonna get some heat at
work because of that whole well like is
the man abusing his power kind of thing
also infidelity's rampant it's illegal
to be unfaithful in the military I don't
know if people know that you can
actually write about work yeah yeah you
can get a write-up at work if you cheat
on your spouse as the service member so
people don't like to take those kinds of
risks I see people cheat on deployment
though
um so I used to work for him him he was
a medical provider he was always very
kind to me and he wasn't condescending
and I liked that because you make a
certain Rank and these guys just have
really huge heads
and we always treated me like a person
and I always learned from him so when my
divorce rolled around I had I maintained
a friendship with him after I got out of
the military so I get out of the
military I get divorced and all of a
sudden he looked like a snack so we just
built a friendship and I know I know how
that looks but like life is not black
and white and it happens like monkey
branching happens whether I knew I was
doing it or not that's how I was going
to look and I I don't mind because like
I I'm the one in the relationship am I
really going to care what these people
are thinking when I'm 60 like I got the
man of my dreams it happens no that's
something you are so cute like the way
you talk about him is literally and I
could tell he like really supports what
you're doing